okay today I'm going to talk to you
about limiting factors of photosynthesis
just a quick introduction photosynthesis
is the process by which plants make
their own food in the form of glucose
I've got another video that tells you
more about this but just to summarize
the plants take in carbon dioxide and
water and they produce glucose and
oxygen what we're going to look at is
three different things that can that are
limiting factors of photosynthesis so
the first one is light now each of these
limiting factors has a particular graph
that we need to know the shape of we
need to understand and be able to
explain the shape of so each time we
write rate that's rate of photosynthesis
so first of all we need to think about
light intensity now photosynthesis this
is the the word equation but we need
light in order for it to to happen so
the shape of the graph looks like this
let me explain it so it's zero light
intensity so if there's no light at all
as you can see there's no rate of
photosynthesis there will be no rate
reaction whatsoever because we need
light in order for the reaction to occur
so as we increase the light intensity
the rate of photosynthesis increases as
well so we can see it's directly
proportional up to a certain point and
then the graph levels out it reaches a
plateau now what this means is it
doesn't matter how much more we increase
the light intensity after a certain
point we reach a maximum rate of
photosynthesis so after this point here
light is no longer a limiting factor
next up what we need to do next is have
a look at carbon dioxide also known as
co2 so let's have a look for carbon
dioxide now again up the y-axis we have
rate of photosynthesis on the x-axis
we're going to show percentage level of
co2 now this graph looks pretty much
identical
to the to the last one again let's break
it down so if we've got 0% co2 so no
carbon dioxide at all we're going to
have no rate of reaction now the reason
for that is if we have a look at our
reactants we can see that carbon dioxide
is one of the reactants so if we've got
no carbon dioxide we're gonna have no
reaction whatsoever as we increase the
level of carbon dioxide the rate of
reaction is also going to increase only
up just as as the same as light up to a
certain level so after we get to this
point here we reach another plateau or
the graph stays at the same point we
reach your kind of maximum point it
means that it doesn't matter how much
more how much we increase the percentage
of carbon dioxide by we're at a maximum
rate of reaction so we can see obviously
it works best they've got a first rate
reaction a higher percentage level of
co2 but after a while we reach a plateau
again now the third one we need to know
about is temperature so the final graph
now this one looks a little bit
different than the other two so again
we've got rate of reaction here but this
time we have a graph that looks like
this
you might recognize this graph from when
we were looking at enzymes so along here
we have temperature so as we can see
initially if you've got a really low
temperature we're going to have a really
really slow rate of reaction that's
because the reactants don't have much
energy as we increase the temperature
we've given these reactants more energy
so therefore we're going to have an
increased rate of reaction all the way
up to a particular optimum now this
optimum temperature will be slightly
different depending on which plants
we're looking at and the reason for this
is as well is the
reaction for photosynthesis is
controlled by enzymes so as we increase
the temperature we're giving the
particles the reactants the enzymes more
kinetic energy so we're gonna have more
reactions sorry more frequent reactions
only up to a certain point because what
happens if you have watched my other
video about enzymes is after a certain
point the enzymes start to denature so
that means the actives they change shape
and the substrate can no longer fit in
the active site so at around this point
here at 45 degrees C normally we can see
that these enzymes have been denatured
which means we now have no rate of
reaction at all because all the enzymes
have been denatured so just to kind of
summarize the best conditions possible
for photosynthesis would be really
bright sand lots of white light high
concentration or high percentage level
of carbon dioxide and the right
temperature a little bit shorter 45
because if we go too hot the enzymes
that control photosynthesis denature
thank you